H
GREAT REPORTING RIGHT FROM WHERE
IT'S HAPPENING IN DEL RIO, TEXAS
ALSO JOINING US FROM TEXAS, IS
KARL ROVE, HE'S RIGHT HERE ON
THE COUCH, HE'S A CONTRIBUTOR
AND FORMER DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF
TO FORMER PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH AND A RESIDENT OF TEXAS THE
PERFECT GUEST TO COME IN AND
TELL US WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
TEXAS.
>> IT'S A MESS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
BRIAN:  DEMOCRATS WANT NO PART
OF THIS STORY.
>> NONE AND IT'S AMAZING TO ME
THE GOVERNMENT HAS AN OBLIGATION
TO TELL US WHAT IT'S DOING AND
NOBODY HAS COME OUT AND SAID
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE DOING, HERE'S
HOW MANY WE SENT BACK TO HAITI
AND HOW MANY WE'RE DISTRIBUTING
INSIDE THE UNITED STATES AND THE
REASON WHY WE'RE TAKING SOME
PEOPLE RETURNING THEM AND THE
REASON WHY WE'RE PARENT LOU
ING SOME PEOPLE TO REMAIN IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE FOUND OUT, HOWEVER,
NORMALLY WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
TAKE AND SAY YOU'RE HERE
ILLEGALLY BUT THE REASONS THAT
ALLOW YOU TO REMAIN IS WE'LL
GIVE YOU A COURT DATE, INSTEAD
THEY ARE NOW SAYING HERE'S A
NOTICE TO APPEAR BEFORE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS WHICH IS NOT CARRY
WITH IT THE SAME KIND OF PENALTY
RACHEL: HOW DO YOU LOCATE THEM
TO TELL THEM WHEN TO COME TO
COURT?
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
PETE HEGSETH WAS JUST ON EARLIER
, AND HE SAID THAT THESE
FLIGHTS ARE GOING OUT INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY,
WITH THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
HAITIAN AND OTHERWISE.
BRIAN:  I.C.E. FLIGHTS.
RACHEL: EXACTLY IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT SO THERE IS YOUR
TRANSPARENCIES FOR YOU.
IF IT WAS ALL ON THE UP AND UP
WHY WOULD IT HAPPEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY, WHY DON'T
WE KNOW THE NUMBER?
>> I DON'T MAKE MUCH OF THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT BECAUSE
THEY PROCESS THEM DURING THE DAY
AND THEY MAY LAUNCH THE FLIGHT
AT 7:00 OR  8:00 OR  1:00 IN THE
MORNING, BUT WE NEED TO KNOW
AND YOU'LL NOTICE YESTERDAY,
SENATOR JOHNSON, FROM YOUR HOME
STATE --
BRIAN:  THEY GOT EVERYONE
FRUSTRATED, EXCEPT FOR MAYORKAS
HIMSELF, LISTEN.
>> HOW MAN ILL PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
RETURNED, HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
BEING DETAINED, HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DISBURSED TO ALL
POINTS AROUND AMERICA?
>> SENATOR I BE PLEASED TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT.
>> I WANT THEM NOW.
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE THAT
INFORMATION NOW?
>> SENATOR I DO NOT HAVE THAT
DATA.
>> WHY NOT.
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE THAT BASIC
INFORMATION?
STEVE: WELL, CARL --
RACHEL: BASIC?
STEVE: THE SECRETARY DOESN'T
WANT TO ADMIT THE NUMBERS THEY
KNOW THE NUMBERS, THERE WAS A
TWEET SENT OUT YESTERDAY AND HE
SAID ACCORDING TO TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY, AS
OF THIS MORNING, THERE WERE
332 HUSBAND/WIFE COMBINATIONS
WHERE THE WIFE IS PREGNANT UNDER
THE BRIDGE IN DEL RIO.
NOW, WE'RE GOING TO BREAK DOWN
THE NUMBERS AND FIGURE THIS OUT.
THERE WERE 6,700 FAMILY UNITS.
WE KNOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS GOING TO LET THEM IN.
1,500 SINGLE MALES THEY HAVE TO
GO BACK, 493 SINGLE FEMALES.
>> YEAH AND REMEMBER THIS
NUMBER IS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE
WE HAVE A STATIC GROUP OF 14,000
PEOPLE THERE.
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY FLOWING
ACROSS THE BORDER, CONSTANTLY
BEING EITHER RETURNED TO HAITI
OR  MORE LIKELY RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES, AND LET'S GO
BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF THIS
THOUGH.
WHY ARE ALL THE HAITIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN BY AND LARGE
THROUGHOUT CENTRAL AND SOUTH
AMERICA FOR MUCH OF THE PAST
YEAR, WHY ARE THEY NOW
SHOWING UP?
THERE'S SOME KIND OF AN ORGANIZ
ED EFFORT THERE AND IF
WE GOT TO THE BOTTOM OF IT, I
WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF IT
WERE NOT THE CARTEL SAYING HEY
YOU'RE HAITIAN, GUESS WHAT, GIVE
US $1,000, GIVE US $2,000, WE'LL
HELP YOU GET UP THERE AND YOU'LL
BE HOME FREE.
STEVE: WELL, CARL, THAT'S
BECAUSE IN MAY THE
ADMINISTRATION GAVE THEM A
TEMPORARY PRO PROTECTED STATUS
FOR ANOTHER 18 MONTHS.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE OF THE
EARTHQUAKE.
RACHEL: SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
SPECULATE THE REASON WHY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ESSENTIALLY OPENED OUR BORDERS
IS THEY THINK IN, THEY BELIEVE
IN OPEN BORDERS BUT, IN THE
FUTURE, THEY WILL BENEFIT
POLITICALLY FROM ALL THESE NEW
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO WILL EVENTUALLY
BE VOTERS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE POLITICS TEXAS IS A HOT
LY CONTESTED STATE.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS DREAM OF
TAKING TEXAS.
WHAT ARE THE POLITICS IN TEXAS
OF THIS.
ARE THERE ENOUGH MIGRANTS TO
TURN THAT OR  ARE THEY TURNING
OFF DEMOCRATS IN SUCH GREAT NUMB
BERMS THAT IT'S NOT THAT.
>> IN PHYSICS I THINK IT'S A
NEWTON LAW FOR  EVERY ACTION
THERE'S AN OPPOSITE REACTION.
JUST REMEMBER WHAT ARE THE
COUNTIES IN AMERICA THAT
MOVE MORE DRAMATICALLY TOWARDS
THE REPUBLICANS IN 2020 AS
COMPARED TO 2016 AND
YOU'LL FIND A BUNCH ARE THEY
HEAVILY HISPANIC COUNTIES AMONG
THE RIO GRANDE RIVER, PART OF IT
WAS ENERGY, BUT A LOT OF IT WAS
WAIT A MINUTE IT'S OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE BEING
ADVERSELY AFFECTED FIRST BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IT'S OUR HOSPITALS.
IT'S OUR SOCIAL SERVICES.
IT'S OUR COMPASSION.
IT'S THE SAFETY OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT'S BEING
AFFECTED AND THAT WAS A BIG
REASON WHY A LOT OF TEHANOS SAID
I'M VOTING REPUBLICAN BECAUSE
THEY ARE SAYING WE OUGHT TO HAVE
A BORDER.
WE CAME HERE LEGALLY OR  THROUGH
A PROCESS, THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
AND THEY'RE HURTING OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BRIAN:  56% OF TEXAS RESIDENTS
WERE ASKED, THE HISPANIC TEXAS
RESIDENTS WERE ASKED ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE OF PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
56% DISAPPROVED OF HIS
PERFORMANCE IN TEXAS.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD SIGN IF YOU
WANT TO TURN TEXAS BLUE.
>> NO AND LOOK, WE GOT ROBERT
FRONT SAYS GETTING READY TO RUN
FOR GOVERNOR, HE'S ABOUT AS FAR
LEFT WING AS HE CAN, HE WILL NOT
BE WELL RECEIVED IN A GENERALLY
CONSERVE CONSERVATIVE COMMUNITY
THAT IS PRO LIFE, PRO MILITARY,
PRO AMERICA, PRO SMALL BUSINESS,
PRO ENTERPRISE.
BRIAN:  HE'S GOT A LOT OF MONEY.
>> WE'LL SEE.
RACHEL: THERE ARE REAL
CONSEQUENCES I HAVE A FRIEND WHO
LIVES IN MISSION, TEXAS, WHO
SAYS THAT HOSPITALS ARE
ABSOLUTELY OVERWHELMED AND THAT
AMERICAN CHILDREN ARE HAVING TO
TRAVEL 100 MILES AWAY.
>> TO CORPUS CRISTI.
RACHEL: FOR SERVICES IN THEIR
LOCAL HOSPITALS ARE FULL WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> ABSOLUTELY TRUE, I WAS IN
CORPUS CRISTI AND SOMEBODY SAID
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING
UP FOR ELECTIVE SURGERY AT OUR
HOSPITALS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE
TAKEN CAROLINA OF.
STEVE: SO DONALD TRUMP PRETTY
MUCH STOPPED THE FLOW AT THE END
OF HIS ADMINISTRATION AND JOE
BIDEN TURNED IT BACK ON.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU'RE THE
PRESIDENT YOU HAVE VAST
POWER OVER HOW THE LAWS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE IMPLEMENT
ED BUT ULTIMATELY IF
PEOPLE WANT TO GET ANYTHING
CHANGED, AND WHEN YOU WERE IN
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION, GEORGE
BUSH TRIED TO GET IMMIGRATION
REFORM DONE, AND YOU KNOW, FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS HE COULDN'T
EVEN GET HIS OWN PARTY.
>> IT WASN'T HIS OWN PARTY THAT
KILLED IT, IT WAS PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA AND THEN SENATOR
OBAMA WHO PROMISED TO SUPPORT
CONFIDENCE OF IMMIGRATION REFORM
VOTING FOR ALL OF THE KILLER
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR OF NORTH DAKOTA HELPED
BY SENATOR HARRY REID.
STEVE: SO HOW DO WE FIX IT?
>> FIRST YOU'VE GOT TO START BY
BORDER SECURITY.
IT TOOK US FOUR YEARS OR  ALMOST
FIVE YEARS TO END CATCH AND
RELEASE, TO GET IN PLACE ALL OF
THE PROCESSES NECESSARY TO SAY
TO PEOPLE, IF YOU COME HERE,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BE RELEASED OUT INTO SOCIETY AND
ESCAPE CONSEQUENCES SO FIRST
THING YOU GOT TO DO IS SECURE
THE BORDER THAT'S WHY IT'S SMART
FOR GOVERNOR ABBOTT TO SAY IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT
SPEND THE MONEY TO BUILD THE
WALL WE'LL SPEND $2 BILLION
OF TEXAS MONEY TO BUILD THE WALL
AND THE UNFINISHED PLACES IN
ORDER TO GET BETTER CONTROL OVER
OUR BORDER AND IT'S WHY TEXAS IS
SPENDING TENS, IF NOT HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S OUR COMMUNITY BEING
AFFECTED AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT
STEP UP AND DO THE JOB IT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
BRIAN:  THAT DRONE TEAM HAS PUT
MORE PRESSURE ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAN ANYTHING
ELSE, BECAUSE NO ONE --
>> THAT AND THAT SMART YOUNG
REPORTER AT THE WHITE HOUSE
NAMED PETER DOOCY.
WHO IS THAT GUY ANYWAY, WHERE
DID HE COME FROM?
STEVE: HE'S GOT